she-hulk fans rejoice the rumor mill may
have given us a clue as that when
Jennifer Walters will finally appear in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
sources close to cosmic book news have
indicated that Marvel may be looking at
the third solo spider-man film to
introduce the character and while this
is little more than speculation for now
there are a couple of factors working in
the rumors favour first there's an
offhand remark that spider-man far from
home star Tom Holland made a couple
months back in an interview with fandom
pollen was bandying about the names of
several interesting characters whom he'd
like to one day see in the MCU from Nick
Fury jr. to RiRi Williams also known as
iron hearts but in the middle of all
this Holland took time to explain that
he'd love to see Spidey team-up with
Mark Ruffalo's Hulk in a future
adventure Holland explained Hulk is so
funny and they're both science geeks and
while Jennifer Walters isn't quite the
same character as Bruce Banner an
appearance by Hulk and spider-man 3
could easily set up the introduction of
Walters who in the comics is banners
cousin best of both worlds more
interesting however is the alleged plot
that Marvel is cooking up for the third
solo Spidey outing although you'll need
to take this with a healthy dose of salt
cosmic book news reports that youtuber
tbo has the skinny straight from inside
sources that the plots of Marvel's third
spider-man flick will follow directly
from far from homes mid credit sequence
in which blowhard vlogger Jay jonah
Jameson publicly reveals doctored
footage making it appear as if Spidey
not Mysterio had been to blame for the
staged elemental attacks on various
European locales in fact this footage
even puts Spidey on the hook for
straight up killing Mysterio and the
villain with his supposed dying breath
reveals the webslinger secret identity
to the world according to TVO sources
the third flick will see Peter Parker
attempting to clear his name through the
proper channels that is the legal system
apparently the idea was put forth that
acting as Parker's defense attorney
would be none other than Matt Murdock
also known as daredevil a situation for
which there is ample precedent in the
comics and I'm a Catholic I have a soft
spot for hopeless causes unfortunately
that plot would be tricky to pull off as
part of the deal struck between Netflix
and Marvel reportedly none of the
characters who appeared in the
streamer's now-defunct slate at Marvel
series are eligible for use in the MC
until 2 full years after each respective
series is cancellation that means that
Marvel Studios would have to wait for a
while before bringing Murdock in to play
in any capacity rather than deal with
the possibility of having to adjust the
timetable for production on the next
Spidey flick Marvel's brain trust simply
defaulted to the next most well-known
attorney in all of Marvel or Walters in
the comics hotshot lawyer Jennifer
Walters his shots and previously injured
by a vengeful gangster while in town for
a visit she receives a blood transfusion
from dear cousin Bruce leading to
Walters becoming the savage she-hulk the
character has gone through quite an
evolution since she first debuted as she
retains her intellect and personality
post transformation she even eventually
decides to just remain hulked out
permanently even in the course of her
day job as a defense lawyer although
TVO's sources didn't let on as to
whether Walters would appear in Hirsch
evil persona during the film there's
something to be said for the idea of
Parker being represented in court by a
giant green superhero lawyer at any rate
it's important to reiterate that this is
an unverified rumor still it would be a
pretty cool way to introduce Walters
into an MCU that could sorely use a new
Hulk
especially now that banner is probably
undergoing intensive physical therapy
after that whole Infinity Gauntlet thing
went down that looked like it hurt check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]